العالم باسره شاهد الصور المرعبه حدث ذلك
على متن طائره تابعه لشركه ايجيانا وطبعا
كلنا شفنا الفيديو وكلنا اجانا كوابيس من
ورا خلونا نتذكر ما الذي حصل قبل دقائق من
الهبوط في كوريا الجنوبيه فتح راكب باب
احدى الطائرات لحسن الحظ الطائره كانت على
وشك الهبوط
القصه اليوم ان هذه الشركه قررت ان تتوقف
عن بيع مقاعد مخارج الطوارئ وهي مقاعد
مرغوبه عاده لانه في مجال انه الواحد
دائما يكون عنده مساحه اكبر
لرجليه وقدمه وربما تكون المسبحه وينتهي
هذا المقعد الى الابد الشرطه كانت تحتجزه
الرجل الذي تسبب في الحادث والذي قال انه
شعر باختناق واراد النزول من الطائره
بسرعه وقال ايضا انه كان يعاني نفسيا بسبب
فقدانه وظيفته
ومشاهدينا ناقشنا
اونا اليوم عن هذه المقاعد تحديدا خارطه
المقاعد عموما في الطائره من وجهه نظر
الراكب وايضا من وجهه نظر
اذا
سلامه الطيران ليست مجرد وظيفه وظيفه
الطياره او طاقم الضيافه فانها تتطلب من
الجميع العمل لتحقيق الامان بالفعل اداره
الطيران الامريكيه تنصح بالانتباه الى
تعليمات السلامه للمضيفات في بدايه الرحله
حيث مخارج الطوارئ مختلفه في
كل طاع عن الاخرى لذا انتبهوا الراكب
الجالس في المقاعد القريبه من ابواب
الطوارئ مسؤول عن فتح المخرج عند الضروره
ويجب ان يكون بامكانه تنفيذ اجراءات
الاخلاء بسرعه حزام الامان ليس رفاهيه
طبعا يجب ارتدائه عند الجلوس وليس فقط عند
الاقلاع والغبوط هو خاصه عندما تضاء علامه
حزام الامان وطبعا عند مرور الطائره
بمطبات هوائيه اخيرا حين يطلب الطاقم من
الركاب اخلاء الطائره من الضروريه ان يتبع
الجميع التعليمات تعليمات الطاقه ويغادر
الطائره في اسرع وقت ممكن هذا يعني ترك
الامتعه الشخصيه التخلي عن الاحذيه اجلكم
الله ذات الكعب العالي وغيرها
[موسيقى]
طيب في الاستوديو انضم الينا الكابتن
مروان اميره دربي صباح الخير صباح النور
سلامه الطائرات كيفك امير خليني اسهل
بدايه التنانين انه اليوم عفوا مروان ابو
امير ان شاء الله طيب خليني اسال بانه
اليوم غير مقعد كابتن الطائره اي المقاعد
اكثر
براحه وامانه خاصه اذا راح هذا المقعد
المقاعد اللي على الاجنحه بالعاده بتلاحظ
انه في مسافه اكبر ليش مش بس اللي راحت
البني ادم بس اذا صار في حال اخلاء طائره
المماري بكون سهل على الاطلاع من الطياره
فالب هدول اكثر مقاعد حساسه في الطياره بس
بنفس الوقت مريحه
فمش كل حدا بيقدر يقعد في هالمقاعد في
عندك حسب
العمر بيلعب دور ما بيخلوش الاطفال يقعدوا
على هدول تحت على الاجنحه صحيح
مخارج الطوارئ صحيح تحت 8 سنين بالعاده
الناس اللي عندها مشاكل صحيه كمان ما
بتقدر تقعد بهالمقاعد ليش اذا صار في هذا
الاخلاق من الطياره يقدروا يساعدوا الناس
كمان عن فتح الابواب وتطلعهم من الطياره
هذه المقاعد تحولت في الاونه الاخيره الى
الى يعني تجاريه منه بعض الطيران تاخذ
زياده بقيمه التذكره حتى انه تعطيك هذه
المساحه اللي ترتاح فيها لكن المسؤوليه هل
تكتفي فقط هل ذلك يكفي انه تسال الراكب
انت مستعد لتحمل المسؤوليه وتساعد راح
يقول ايه حتى يحظى بالمقعد هل هذا كافي لا
يجب الانسان يعرف وظيفه المقاعد هذه مش بس
للراحه المسؤوليه كلها عند هذا الشخص في
يوم الاخلاع لا سمح الله فنحن بالعاده مثل
ما قلت انت كل بيقول اه بس بالوقت الضروره
الانسان هذا هو اللي يقدر انه هو ينقذ
الناس كلها ليش لانه اخلاء الطياره بشكل
عام لك 90 ثانيه انك تخلق كامل الطياره
يعني انت تعرف الايه بس الايبس 380
873 راكب ب 90 ثانيه
وعملوا
تجربات واخلاق ب 70 ثانيه طيب معناته ب
يعني اكيد في خطه اخلاء عاده بتكون
للطائره بحسب حجمها وعدد ركابها ولكن
كابتن لو اخذنا خريطه المقاعد خريطه مقاعد
الطائره في عندك الجزء الاول اللي هو
مقدمه الطائره لغايه الاجنحه منطقه
الاجنحه بعدين
الجزء الاخير من الطائره وعند الذيل انو
اكثرها امانا وبعرف انه الفرقيه كتير
قليله مش مستاهل ولكن هلا بس عشان نتطمن
المقاعد
او مراكز الاخلاء
بالطياره اخترعوها لسبب ليش لانه الاخلاق
من الاجنحه ومن الذنب اكثر امان للطائره
يعني مثلا اللي بده ينط من الطياره من
قدام
لا سمح الله ما طلع السلايد
اللايف تبعها
الاجنحه بتساعدوا على ان ينزل من الطياره
وبنفس ولكن لا سمح الله لو صار اي مشكله
في الطائره هل بتفرق انت وين قاعد
هل عندك
حتى لو اعلى بشوي انك انك تنجو اذا قاعد
في منطقه معينه معينه ما في بس الطياره
حسب حجمها حسب النوع تبع الطياره
الاخلاق من قدام وبالنص من وراء اكثر سرعه
في الطياره وهذا الاحصائيه مش حصلت على مش
انه التسعين ثانيه مش على كل المراكز
الابواب عن نصهم طيب كابتن مروان يعني
الراكب الكوري اللي فتح الباب كيف يمكن ان
يفتح هذا الباب وكيف يمكن انه والله بهذه
السهوله انه بالضبط اني افتح الباب ليش ما
يكون مثلا في لوك في في لوكس عاده في بعض
الطيرانات
الطاقم الطائره يكون موجود بالقرب من هذه
صحيح هو اللي فتح الباب يعني الناس بس كان
كان مصر انه يفتح الباب لان الباب بده جهد
صحيح صحيح بده جهد انك تفتح الباب ولكن
الطياره مضغوطه بس
الارتفاع اللي فتح الباب عليه 800 قدم
وارتفاع جدا يعني تقريبا بعد ثواني
كابتن بسؤال الاخير وسؤال المليون ليش صوت
الكابتن مو واضح بالطياره شكرا جزيلا
حبيبي
[ضحك]
بيكون في واضح ما
الكابتن انا عندي مشاكل
يعني خلاص كابتن مروان امير الدربي شكرا
جزيلا لك شكرا لك خبطنا هبوطا سليما واحنا
الحمد لله على سلامه الوصول هبط الينا هنا
في الاستوديو من غير ما بالله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات